laura you're so incredible in so many
things that you do and this is really no
exception you are unrecognizable
physically yeah i mean you look at you i
don't know who was like oh yeah laura
benanti she can play amy schumer's
mother you look
how how did amy i mean amy and i did a
play on broadway together called meteor
shower that steve martin wrote of course
and we became
sorry steve martin
i know same same that was me every day
in rehearsal just like
um but yeah so we did we became friends
that way and then she just saw i think a
quality in me where she felt like you
can do this and we'll figure it out
we'll put a wig on you we'll give you
prosthetics at least in the first
episode where i'm you know an older
woman and then all of the other
subsequent episodes i'm in flashback but
yeah she she saw you just need a person
to be like i see you and then yeah
you're good
right
what is amy schumer like as a director
she's incredible she's able to be like
okay this is how you hear something best
this is how you hear something best and
then she just
frames it in such a way that you feel
like you came up with it yourself well
this show is gaining so much steam and
for all the right reasons it is
incredibly introspective it is beautiful
it is haunting and it's just
fantastically acted it's so good yay i'm
so glad you like it
thank you i'm so glad you like it um
well we're here at the desk laura i
wanna have some headlines i really do
itv news reports portland oregon just
got its first sports bar for women
[Applause]
i love it so much
i love the name of the bar
it's called the sports bra
a genius name thought up by owner jenny
nguyen a former college basketball
player herself the walls are decked out
with the jerseys of incredible female
athletes the bar menu is sourced from
women-owned businesses and on the tvs
only women's sports only women
i love it
the sports room might be the first
women's sports bar on the planet i want
to go there now i'm glad to know it
exists it makes me happy it's just so
fantastic
yeah i know it's going to be a success
because i heard about and thought that
doesn't already exist i know and when
you can lock into something that duh
should be a thing that's when it takes
over the world so watch out
the sports bra is coming to a town near
you event yeah right now so hashtag
franchise exactly exactly well up next
what about this story uh a very
important subject everybody what is your
pet's name and what does it say about
you study finds reports people are
judging you for your pet's name really a
new survey found six out of ten people
say they'll actually judge you for what
you name your pet and i kind of get this
because if i meet you and you're like oh
this is my cat fluffy i'm like i roll
next okay good to know you're
i think i'm one of the people that judge
your pet's name should be interesting
don't you think
well my pet's names are their two little
rescues and um pewdiepie
and lily oh that's my daughter she's
that's my daughter ella and my super
amazing husband patrick he holds
pewdiepie like a baby because she had
she had to have surgery when we got her
she was so abused they both were and we
really like nursed them back to health
especially my husband so pewdiepie and
lily rose where does pewdiepie come from
so
bernadette peters yeah you know an icon
yes she works with so many shelters and
she recommended one love for animals
which is the organization that that we
went to
so pewdiepie so she was named sweetie
pie when we first got her and i was like
pewdiepie for bernadette peters that's
perfect yeah what are your dog's things
well i have i have three i have three
rescues there they are look so the
closest one is audrey for like audrey
hepburn because she has bold eyebrows
and
the second one is selena after selena
the singer bitty bitty bum bum yeah
because she's curvy and um then paw earl
in the back is named after my great
grandpa because i adopted him at 12 and
that was like the oldest name i could
think of wait i love that and you have
what are your dogs named douglas douglas
and lucy cute names that's douglas on
the right and that's lucy on the left
all right so start judging everyone
um
laura benanti you are so amazing life
and beth is no exception it's on hulu
right now everybody's talking about it
for a very good reason please watch it
it is phenomenal
[Music]